coach congratulations how do you feel
today I'm a bit tired DP I appreciate
you having me on but uh it's uh it's a
good tired that's for sure so excited
for our team and excited for for
cognition when you watch the game film
of Lamar Jackson I don't know if you get
to a point where you say I got to turn
this off because it's starting to make
me nervous here what did you see on tape
and how did you take advantage of that
when you face somebody as great as him
oh I I did I did turn it off at that
point and just say you know what nobody
stopped him we're not going to stop him
I you know again we didn't stop him
necessarily last night but I think the
plan going in and credit to Todd Orlando
and our defensive staff was to say we're
going to put the pressure on and we're
going to pressure him every single snap
and we're going to make it very
uncomfortable for him in the pocket and
he may make a few guys miss and Buster a
big run and and and that's okay and
we're going to live with that and we're
going to continue to pressure them
because I just don't think a guy of that
magnitude and again I in my opinion
Lamar Jackson still the best player in
college football on still the the
Heisman Trophy frontrunner there's no um
you know no doubt about that in my mind
but I think if you just sit back and
cover everybody in the past name and
then you know let the guy you know sit
back diagnose everything and then say
okay everybody's covered and take off
and run and you're going to be in for a
long night and we wanted to force the
action we wanted to pressure him we
wanted to pressure his o-line make him
make quick decisions in the throw game
and then if possible hit home and and we
did that he wasn't the best player on
the field he might be the Heisman Trophy
winner but he wasn't the best player on
the field last night coach I you may say
that I know
ed ed Oliver and Oliver was the best
player on the field last night well ed
ed has shown up in big games for us
showing up in numerous games for us but
yeah he has definitely you know we
played the number three ranked team in
the country twice this year that's uh I
don't know if credit is the right word
but you know thank you for Mac to macros
sarcastically our previous athletic
director for scheduling those games but
yeah ed Oliver has shown up in a big way
in in those games and he's shown up all
season he's a guy that is extremely
explosive extremely disruptive and has a
tremendous motor and plays you know like
his hair's on fire every single snack
how did he get number 10 though coach
he's the nose tackle on he got number 10
funny story about that he got number 10
because he wore number 11 in high school
and he said I want to wear number 11 at
the University of Houston I said great
the numbers retired because that's Andre
wears number you can call Andre where
and ask him and and he did and and Andre
to his credit said you know what not
selfishly not because it's andre ware
but because of what that number
represents and all of andre's teammates
and the kind of era that Andre played in
he was a bit apprehensive and and ed
understood that and thanked him and said
okay I'll wear number 10 and it's been
such a weird season because a couple of
months ago i'm talking to you your names
in the headlines you guys are undefeated
we're thinking maybe this game last
night was going to be for something like
playing for the national championship
putting in the Final Four then you lose
to Navy and SMU how do you explain this
season
well I I explained it in that you know
when we're fresh and we're healthy I
think we can play with anybody in the
country this was the first time believe
it or not dan this was the first time
that every single person every single
player that played in the oklahoma game
was cleared medically to play in a game
against louisville so we had gone ten
straight weeks without you know
basically are all of our starters and
our key backups cleared to play so and
that's not an excuse we need to our tues
and our backups need to play better but
the month of October was was it nine for
us we played five games in a month of
September we played four games and a
19-day stretch there in September and it
caught up to us in the month of October
and we finally got healthy we didn't
have our bye week until week 10 and we
got healthy we got fresh and like I said
I think you know when we're at peak
physical condition I think you know we
can play with anybody we just hadn't
been that way in a long time talking to
Tom Herman Houston head coach joining a
Stan Patrick show after the win last
night over Louisville I know your name
was splattered all over college football
with the possible job openings there and
it since subsided a little bit I don't
know what that means about your coaching
like you're not the same coaches you
were two months ago or you know whatever
whatever it is maybe it's a good thing
allowed you to sort of go back to just
coach and not answer these kind of
questions but here we are a nine and two
season just beating louisville is your
wife allowed to bring up this topic at
home is my wife law to bring up the
topic at home I didn't know no no
nobody's allowed to bring up the topic
at home I think you know we are
committed to giving a hundred percent to
the University of Houston we owe that to
University of Houston and we're not
going to answer
questions about any other jobs and you
know it I would be doing these these
kids I I love our players so much dan
that it would be a complete disservice
for me to give any an ounce of thought
to anything else but giving them a
hundred percent to win a game each week
and look I appreciate that but if I'm
your wife there's part of me that just
says just give me a heads up when we're
allowed to talk about this you know we
staying here we can assign an extent you
know you know what are we doing here
that that has to be a part of just
marriage there of what the future thank
god you're not my wife yeah and that's
up that would be an awful thing but no
III think you know it's part of the
business you know and we we have moved
and it's part of the business that we
love about the University of Houston
we've moved I think there was a stretch
in our career that we moved six times in
10 years and you know Michelle and our
family has been through a lot in this
career and I think that's one of the
beauties of the University of Houston is
having that stability and being able to
say you know what this is our home we've
built a home here we love the University
of Houston and you know we were not
focused on anything else other than that
did you think Houston was going to get
into the big 12 man you are a really
good question asker by the way um did I
think so yeah I did to be quite honest
with you I I don't know again I didn't
concern myself at all with things that I
can't control but when you you know sit
back and and you've got a spare a few
seconds you you think about the
opportunities for the big 12 way I mean
what were they
the best candidate for conference
expansion in the entire country
regardless of it if it's a big 12 you
know we've got a tier 1 academic
institution or in the fourth largest
market in the country and we're playing
really good football right now and and
we're making unbelievable upgrades GF
facilities and to our program so I
really thought that if the big 12 did
expand that that we were a no brainer
but I feel that way about any conference
expanding to be quite honest with you DP
yeah I thought and you don't to answer
but I thought if you got into the big 12
more than likely you know Houston could
be your home for quite some time and
maybe it maybe it's going to be but I
thought going into the big 12 puts you
guys into a different category there and
you know you'd be viewed differently
that the school would be football team
would be but hey congrats well we'll
have a conversation maybe after the
season or maybe we don't have a
conversation about your future after the
season but good luck against Memphis
congrats on the big win last night as
well coach all right then I appreciate
you having me as always man go Cougs all
right that's done Tom Herman the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience